y seguimos hablando de que tanto nos ha
afectado a nivel personal la pandemia
con 19 como nos cambió la vida afectiva
hablamos de los besos abrazos la
relación familiar en pareja e incluso
hasta el sexo con el kobe 19 el
sentimiento constante y alerta de
amenaza que nos persigue puede tener
consecuencias en nuestra percepción y
también en la forma en que nos
relacionamos con los demás y para ello
entonces quiero darle la bienvenida a
ana sánchez anegón terapeuta y cio de
animals emocionales gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros
anna en directo américa de france 24
cómo volver a tener esa confianza en el
comportamiento afectivo luego de esta
pandilla y por supuesto seguimos
hablando todavía porque estamos en
pandemia
bueno primero de todo buenos días raúl
estoy encantada de estar aquí con
vosotros para recuperar digamos esa
confianza que tenemos hacia los demás
para poder relacionarnos con los demás
tenemos que tener en cuenta que es muy
importante para nuestra salud el tener
ese esa confianza para poder volver a
vernos de manera física y eso claro es
muy difícil de conseguir cuando tenemos
tantos impactos y sobre todo esa
mentalidad de que existe un miedo
permanente a ser contagiados por eso yo
siempre recuerdo que tenemos que tener
en cuenta que somos animales gregarios
que necesitamos ese contacto físico si
tenemos en cuenta eso si sabemos eso nos
vamos a dar cuenta de que forma parte de
nuestra salud el estar en contacto
físico con los demás y que eso va a
mejorar también nuestro sistema inmune
por eso lo importante es no tener ese
miedo constante para no tener ese miedo
constante es muy importante y aunque
suene contradictorio ser conscientes de
que somos también seres que tenemos que
convivir con el miedo entonces en vez de
hacer desaparezca ese miedo en vez de
decidirnos a vivir sin miedo como si no
existiera ignorando lo tenemos que ser
conscientes de que podemos empezar a
volver a vivir con miedo y empezar a
volver a tenerlo presente en nuestra
vida pero seguir viviendo y seguir
confiando en que podemos superar
cualquier situación de miedo y también
poder estar de nuevo con nuestra familia
con nuestros seres queridos abrazarlos y
tener ese contacto físico que no sea
suficiente el contacto virtual que
aunque también es muy positivo que sea
importante también volver a tener ese
contacto físico ahora también le quiero
preguntar entonces es como este cómic 19
afectó la vida en pareja a nivel íntimo
también de comprensión de comunicación
dentro de la pareja porque también en
muchas ocasiones la pareja estaba
viviendo al mismo techo pero seguramente
tenían todo el día sin hablarse porque
estaban en reuniones luego hablando con
otros familiares que no estaban dentro
de su núcleo y vimos también muchas
parejas con problemas no terminaron
muchísimas separándose porque tampoco
sabían cómo cómo tener esa convive de
mucho tiempo juntos
claro desde luego ha sido una prueba de
fuego para las parejas y por eso hemos
visto tantísimos casos de separación
tantísimos casos de divorcio y también
hemos visto y yo lo he visto en consulta
casos en los que la pareja se ha
fortalecido gracias a este tiempo juntos
y por qué sucede esto
yo lo achaco al estado de vulnerabilidad
que hemos estado expuestos este estado
de vulnerabilidad que forma parte de
nuestra esencia y que es lo que nos hace
más humanos es el sentir miedo el sentir
tristeza el sentir agobio el sentir
estrés hace que esto se proyecte hacia
el otro en la pareja y en función de
como eso sea reciba por el otro porque
la pareja no es más que una
manifestación de nosotros mismos aunque
parezca una persona aislada siempre
vamos a proyectar en esa persona todo lo
que nos sucede todos nuestros miedos en
función de cómo reaccione esa pareja la
relación incluso puede salir fortalecida
en un entorno de confinamiento se ha
visto cómo se dice lo peor y lo mejor de
la persona por qué en una intensidad muy
grande entonces eso ha hecho que haya
muy presas que se han vuelto a conocer
que se han vuelto a que han vuelto a
tener contacto entre ellos y que se
hayan separado porque no hayan podido
digamos superar esta prueba de fuego que
ha hecho que salga lo más esencial de
ellos mismos y otras parejas que sin
embargo como hemos visto pues han
fortalecido su relación gracias a este a
este confinamiento hablamos de la pareja
pero ahora vamos a enfocarnos en la
familia que también han sufrido estos
periodos largos de separación estos
largos períodos como ya lo estaba
adelantando anna generó cambios en el
individuo
claro tenemos que tener en cuenta que la
memoria que nosotros tenemos que la
memoria de
los sucesos más importantes de nuestra
vida son memorias en carne y hueso
nosotros normalmente no recordamos ni
nos emociona pensar en una llamada
telefónica o pensar en un email o un
encuentro virtual con alguien sino que
lo que nos emociona lo que nos hace
sentir esa emoción de alegría y de
fraternidad con la familia son los
momentos que pasamos físicamente son los
momentos de carne y hueso que
compartimos con la familia esto se ve
alterado cuando está prohibido el
contacto físico y cuando encima añadimos
un factor de miedo que hace que no
podamos vernos con tranquilidad con
seguridad había familias que aunque
podían verse al final de la pandemia y
al final siempre utilizaban mascarilla o
siempre utilizaban
protección para no tener contacto por
eso el contacto con la familia se ha
visto muy dañado y lo que recomiendo es
recuperarlo y como decía al inicio
aunque sea con miedo pero recuperarlo
para que podamos volver a sentir y
volver a crear memorias juntos yo soy
muy optimista raúl y yo creo que el ser
humano puede superar cualquier tipo de
situación y por eso invito a la
audiencia a que a que sea capaz de
volver a ese contacto físico que es tan
importante también para su sistema
inmune también hablamos de los amigos ya
rápidamente anna no quiero que esta
pregunta se me quede por fuera de
nuestra conversación porque a veces
también a uno le da como una cierta
pereza salir a socializar con estos
amigos con la gente que nos rodea que
nuestros afectos por qué pasa esto más
allá de la pandemia sentimos también
como bienestar estar en casa yo creo que
también estas nuevas agregaciones
prefieren como que estar un poco más
aisladas que compartir todos como un
grupo
una de las los sucesos que he visto que
me han llamado mucho la atención en esta
pandemia ha sido que las personas han
creado han desarrollado una especie de
ansiedad social una especie de miedo
digamos juzgados oa sentirse vulnerables
frente a nuevas personas frente a otras
personas es como si hubiéramos perdido
el hábito de conocer a gente nueva de
relacionarnos de nuevo y ese y que
quisiéramos evitar digamos ese riesgo de
no gustar sino ese riesgo de no ser
aceptados por el grupo entonces esto se
ha desarrollado porque hemos estado en
un ambiente que aunque era muy duro de
confinamiento nos creaba cierto
bienestar los creaba que no tuviéramos
que tener esas interacciones que son tan
importantes